kamala harris was was asked
sort of a tough question on univision
for goodness sakes univision a very
leftist
television station she was asked a
question about this immigration issue
and she couldn't take the heat and she
snapped
when are you going to the border vice
president administration has
asked i'm not finished
i've said i'm going to the border and
also if we are going to deal with the
problems at the border
we have to deal with the problems that
cause people to go to the border
to flee to the border and that is the
root causes
so my first trip as vice president of
the united states
was to go in terms of a foreign trip to
guatemala
to be on the ground there to address and
to and to be informed of
the root causes why are the people of
guatemala leaving
do you have a date
i i will keep you posted i will keep you
posted i love
good good on this reporter because
everyone's been asking hey kamala you
know you're on this guatemala trip
you're apparently in charge of
immigration now
because joe biden wanted to toss you
right under that bus you remember that
bus
that you said uh brought black students
to white schools that you said joe biden
opposed because joe biden's a terrible
racist and that do you remember that bus
well he's thr you're throwing it right
underneath it because
i think there is no love lost between
joe biden
and kamala harris and he gave her an
impossible job
and she's failing at that impossible job
in a spectacular way so she goes to
guatemala
and she's asked this question when are
you going to the border
and her answer well i'll go eventually
and the reporter says yeah
give me a date i'm not finished i'm
that's
kamala's favorite line she thinks this
plays well i don't think this plays well
i think this plays well
with very angry single feminist women
and that's i guess the democratic base
it's a
big part of the democratic base but it's
not a huge constituency and to the rest
of us
this just seems so shrill
it seems uh unprofessional it seems
deceptive she obviously just doesn't
want to answer the question and then
this reporter doesn't back down good on
her and by the end she goes give me the
date
kamala and kamala goes well i'll keep
you posted which i care it doesn't it
just doesn't matter
this might be bad for her political
career but for the broader
power structures in the country does it
just doesn't really matter
the trip was not a huge success
the way you know this is because it is
being reported in cnn
that white house staffers think it was a
failure now
i just went on a long rant about how i
don't believe things that are in cnn
but i want to make sure we're specific
here
there are different ways of covering
stories
okay when cnn a leftist outlet
covers a republican president like
donald trump
and quotes anonymous white house
staffers i i
generally don't believe it i'm not
saying it's never true but i ju
my dis my inclination is not to believe
it because i know that those two
organizations
are adversaries cnn is out to get trump
trump is out to get cnn so i just don't
buy it
when cnn is reporting on the biden white
house
i'm much more inclined to believe it
because cnn and the biden white house
are not adversaries they're partners
they're on the same team
and so when cnn is reporting something
from the biden white house
it is because biden wants to send a
message
and the message is being sent to kamala
the the white house staffers
believe that she looked ill prepared
according to this report
and and that her bad answers overshadow
this sort of thing
there are it's really worth pointing out
when we're talking about
how to judge propaganda that comes out
of the government or out of the big
corporations or out of the media
they're all kind of part of the same
thing there simply are different
standards
of judging these places when they're
talking about democrats and when they're
talking about republicans
just like there's different standards
when we're talking about a blm terrorist
versus a
capital rioter there are different
standards when we're talking about
democrats and republicans here being
covered if you do not
ring that bell subscribe to this video
then youtube will render me speechless
which is coincidentally the name of my
upcoming book it's going to be released
in 11 days speechless controlling words
controlling minds which is available now
for pre-order
you got to get those notifications you
got to make sure you don't miss a video
and head on over to apple podcast google
play stitcher spotify
gmail hotmail aol instant messenger
subscribe to the michael knowles show
audio podcast leave a five-star review
we'll see you next time